foreign
foreign
this is Norway are now establishing a
message and our Center to enhance the
Norwegian dower if you donate to the
schools you will ensure Allah reap the
rewards of thousands of Muslims coming
back to Islam and many of those who
become Dwight and invite Islam so click
the link and donate now and share the
video for extra Rewards
the three Muslims today we're joined
with three very recognizable faces we
have the conservative Muslims from the
Jubilee video how you guys doing today
how are you
can everyone hear me okay let's do a
sound check for everyone of course
lamia
for some reason I can hear
do you know who it's coming from or is
it from everyone no no it was it's my
bad I had the YouTube channel open so
there you go no worries all right
Bismillah so everyone's already very
excited
this uh this friend here stayed up till
midnight to watch this time
[Laughter]
so I um I was really reluctant to watch
a video because I I don't like watching
Jubilee videos because they've had a
history in being a little leaning to one
side
um clearly the left the liberal the
normal side but everyone was talking
about this it was strange and then
brother Jad popped up on my for you page
and I'm like this feels a little bit
different so before we get into it we're
getting the discussions and all that I
want to ask you guys why did you join
the Jubilee video and how did you come
across that opportunity so let's start
with brother Mahmoud yeah so apparently
they sent an application to my local
Masjid over here and so my friend was
the director of the message so he sent
it he sent it like to the whole group
chat with all the guys
and so I I just like not jokingly but I
just like oh why not let me just join it
because I already know I wasn't aware of
the the channel before but then my my
siblings were like oh it's like BuzzFeed
like that kind of liberal kind of
fun kind of entertainment video so I was
like oh let me just join why not so then
they they rang me up they interviewed me
and you know surprisingly enough uh I
mean I'm sure you two went through it
too you know they they don't know much
about Islam so they were kind of asking
as they go like oh what are some good
topics we can bring on the video stuff
like that so
uh so my intention on there was like
just like the I understand there's a
like a big non-muslim audience so I
wanted to just bring like Islam in a in
a in a very uh simple sense just so
people can understand what it is rather
than oh you guys worship Muhammad and
all this you know
ignorant things about Islam you know I
just wanted to get the true message out
there you know but then again I'm no
student of knowledge I'm no expert I'm
anything I'm just someone trying to get
that the bare minimum
yeah absolutely may I love reward you
for the uh for the intention and for
joining I mean so for uh sister lemie
and brother Jad was it similar for you
guys was it different anyway
um yeah for me so I actually watch
Jubilee I'll be watching I watched the
video sometimes I do find it
entertaining some of their uh like where
they have like one person and then they
have six other people who are like are
not like the real ones and one person to
fake I watch those videos sometimes and
I always was wondering like how do they
get these people on here like because I
know that everyone's in there is a
stranger so I was like wondering like
where do they recruit them or like how
do they get them out so I just looked in
their description and they had a link
like julie.com like casting or something
so I clicked on it and then from there
it tells you like what videos they have
coming up next
and um and it tells you like Middle
Ground which is one of the more like
serious
um segments and then it said the
conservative Muslims versus liberal
Muslims I was like oh shoot I was like
there's something I can actually like
that's relevant to me so it was all kind
of coincidence so that I signed up I was
like it'd be really cool if I was to
like get on there and um after I signed
up they did the interviews and stuff but
the real reason like
one of the reasons that I signed up is
because the main reason that I signed up
is because
um I'm not sure if you had to watch the
previous video on uh with Muslims
included uh it was like one of this it's
called a spectrum I think and it was
like very um
I want to say anything about the people
that were on there but I feel like it
just wasn't a proper representation of
of Muslims so my goal was to at least I
felt like I could do my part in properly
resenting uh representing Muslims and uh
that's the reason that I got on there I
wanted to give people an accurate
representation of what it what it's like
to be a Muslim in America and what our
ideologies are and um
yeah I mean even even though me and
um
feels the same way we didn't agree with
the title of conservative Muslims
liberal Muslims we even told them uh
when recording like throughout the video
we said it they just didn't put it in
there but we told them we don't identify
as conservative is also a thing we're
just Muslims and uh but obviously they
had to keep it there for the title but
uh yeah I think it was for me at least
it was a good experience and
day sir absolutely all right very very
interesting and uh sister lamia how
about you
so um for me I
actually I'm
in America like about a year a year ago
um for college
um I'm actually from Sudan and um I've
always kind of been watching Jubilee's
videos from back home
um mainly because you know I finally
found a channel on YouTube with a with a
large platform and like a large audience
that kind of like
represent Muslims in some way it might
not be an accurate representation like
uh brother Mahmud and Jad said but at
least it's out there
um kind of like teaching Muslims giving
an insight to Muslims
um so when I came here I kind of like
thought it would be a fun idea to kind
of sign up for one of their videos
especially since I kind of I also signed
up for their newsletter and
um when I got the notification that
they're doing a liberal versus
conservative
quote unquote
um debate I thought that I could kind of
like contribute to it maybe kind of give
my own insights especially coming from a
Muslim country a Muslim majority country
and I signed up for it never thinking
that I would actually
um again end up getting the call but
alhamdulillah I did
um I can't really say that I did my best
to kind of represent
um my opinions and express My Views um
as a Muslim woman but
at least it's it's kind of like the the
big First Step so yeah absolutely
honestly I think you guys all did
tremendous I think you all do an amazing
job and um it's funny because when it
comes to the term liberal and
conservative Orthodox traditional
whatever and some people even say
extreme but you know these terms are not
something that we would say is
islamically valid so I'm glad you
mentioned that point brother Judd and
I'm glad to hear that all you know all
of us agree with that um the only people
that really use these terms are the
liberal or the secular or the West
because they inherently don't agree with
Islam but even if these people were to
understand Islam Islamic teachings they
would know that such words and such
um categories don't exist islamically
speaking but only in the secular sense
uh shout out to Brother Ali chabar may
Allah bless you for these super tap
so
now we know how you guys got on to the
uh the Jubilee video but what were your
thoughts going into were you guys
nervous and what was it like when you
first you know met everyone and sat down
and started having those conversations
anyone can take the mic
uh I'll just go ahead and start
um yeah obviously I was nervous
um just because I didn't know who was
going to be on my side you know
alhamdulillah was blessed to have
YouTube with on me with my on my side
you know
um just because like like like Jed said
before you know I know how these kind of
channels work where they get like not
saying I'm perfect or anyone's perfectly
you know but they get someone who maybe
doesn't represent Islam in the best way
so then or non-muslims watch it they get
oh that's what a Muslim is you know
praying three times a day or something
like that you know like my friends have
told me like some of their old videos it
was like that so
so uh so I was obviously I was nervous I
wanted to prepare a bit you know
alhamdulillah uh obviously we could have
done better but um it is what it is but
uh I came in there there's a green room
they were filming another video so we
had to be quiet and also we weren't
allowed to talk to each other so I
didn't know who was who you know I kind
of got and then uh
it was all good though you know I wasn't
too nervous you know because you know
alhamdulillah I know Islam is the Deen
of truth and the dean that has an answer
for everything in life you know even you
know it's the only Dean that has an
answer for inheritance for instance you
know it goes into every aspect of our
life you know I know either whether or
not we could answer it or not I know
there's a place in Islam where I can
find the answer for it you know so I
didn't I didn't have any uh nervousness
in that way you know so yeah absolutely
alhamdulillah and that's I think that's
that's a very beautiful answer
alhamdulillah because as Muslims we're
supposed to be very proud and confident
of our religion but not of ourselves our
knowledge or anything that has to do
with us we're just very proud that we
know our Dean our our religion Islam
covers any single question somebody
could ask that was very beautifully said
and we actually got a super chat for you
that's my voice
and before we we move on with the
question in um I've heard this like way
way too many times even my family
members are saying it
um Issa says brother John reminds me of
Romney in a positive way how he speaks
and behaves himself I've even heard that
like physically we look alike as well if
you guys agree let me know
kind of yeah I see the resemblance yeah
it's a compliment I mean
um for me
um in terms of that question you're
asking me how it was like you're saying
like talking about like right before we
got on right yeah
um so going into it I was a little bit
nervous I was talking to my dad I was
talking to my friend Kareem who's there
with me and um the common theme was
I just like to be nervous about you're
on the side of the Huck
and that's all that matters right so um
that's why I was like I was like that's
true like what do I have to be nervous
about if because I know like the what I
believe and I know that my ideologies
and how I was raised is correct so I
haven't I had nothing to be nervous
about and um it was just a matter of
like in debates it's just a matter of
like are you able to uh pull up the
evidence and pull up the and like have
the the right argument at like instantly
like right away so it was um
it's definitely uh
I think that was like the only like
thing I was scared about like am I gonna
like fold Under Pressure like when uh
someone brings up something that I'm not
expecting like how am I gonna respond
and um when they say something that is
gonna
infuriate me how am I gonna respond and
like because we uh going into I knew
there was going to be some stuff that
was that I was going to disagree with
and it was a matter of keeping keeping
our composure going into it like
thinking about like the right having the
right mindset going into it that this is
um it's not an argument it's a
discussion and uh the goal is to help
not only the people in front of me but
the people that are going to be watching
the video help them understand what
Islam really means and um alhamdulillah
I think we all did our best in doing
that and um yeah so going into it I mean
so beforehand in the interviews they
kind of like subtly like suggested what
was going to be talked about in the
video so then also like knowing the
channel I figured what type of questions
they'd be asking so that's why uh like
some of the ayata obviously some people
think like I was able to just break them
up beforehand some of them I brought up
right on but a couple of them obviously
I knew like what type of topics were
going to be brought up so I needed to I
didn't want to uh butcher the
description or anything like that or the
translation
um so that's why I had to like make sure
that I was I knew that beforehand but
alhamdulillah no complaints and uh
glad to know you guys weren't prepared
yeah all right sister lamia uh for me I
was 100 nervous
I'm nervous because
um I feel like my first barrier was the
language barrier so
especially with when talking about
topics like Islam because I grew up
learning them in Arabic so I tend to
kind of like automatically switch my
brain to Arabic so I was I was kind of
worried of like not finding the right
word in English or like naughty being
able to translate this certain um or
Hadith to English so I kind of got
nervous a little shaky not to mention it
was super hot there
um I I I I kept on sweating like crazy
but at the end of it it was just like
the nerve so
um I couldn't
like like I said Express what I wanted
to say properly but
um
it was overall a pretty like I said it
was a pretty teaching experience like it
kind of teaches you about the other side
I went in kind of like a little prepared
to for like especially like there are
some certain topics that are kind of
like
um what was the word like they're kind
of distinct to Liberal Muslims it's um
like for example like in the topic of
homosexuality and acting upon that that
was kind of like known for me so I kind
of knew what I needed to say for a bit
but then there are some things that I
did not just expect so
um but yeah that was that was pretty
much it I was 100 nervous but
it was a learning experience
it's actually it's very surprising to
hear that you're you're worried about
English because I never in a million a
million years would guess that you have
anything even a shadow of a doubt in
your ability to speak English
yeah yeah is very very Western to be
honest yeah no no it's it's yeah the
accent kind of throws off people a
little bit um it's just because I kind
of like grew up learning about you know
like Western
like all about like the western movies
and and songs and all that we kind of
hear them and not in that so it's kind
of like the accent kind of stuck with me
but there are some like
within some context that I cannot just
like the words just I lose all the words
I see I understand so with that being
said would you would you say that you
got more or less nervous as time went on
did you get more comfortable with
speaking with them or did you become
more worried
um so I think I was I was more
intimidated at first because before the
discussion they kind of like asked you
one-on-one questions
um I think I was nervous more than on
that
um but like more than the discussion
because I feel like I had some backup
from Brother Mahmoud and Jad here in the
discussion but like when they were
asking me one-on-one questions that's
when I got a little nervous but other
than that it was a little Chiller during
the discussion okay alhamdulillah that's
that's good to hear that it got more
chill as time went on usually with these
discussions especially with you know
discussions that are so you know
emotional for people exactly a little
crazier yeah that's good to hear
alhamdulillah um how about you Mahmoud
and brother do you guys have a similar
experience or
uh I just want to add something actually
yeah
um
uh when I when I was doing the interview
uh the the the director wanted me to
bring a thought for the video you know
for like the thumbnail I believe but the
funny part is that uh okay I was like
okay if you want me to do it I'll just
do it you know just for the just for the
like joke of it kinda yeah you know but
then again I I I ended up bringing it on
the side just to I wanted to prove a
point to them because I want to say in
the end that I was like you know as a
Muslim no matter what quote-unquote
conservative mind like title you want to
give or anything you know uh you know as
a Muslim we were supposed to wear as
like other Society does you know I don't
want to give some weird impression you
know you know you know that that weird
kind of mindset where people wear at
kufi and a phobe and a big beard and oh
my God he's so religious and all that
kind of stuff you know because I want to
give the true impression of who I am you
know I don't I wear I wear American
clothing you know and and you know I
would have thought sometimes but like
that's not the true impression I want to
give of who we are as mostly me you know
so yeah I just want to throw that in
there so just just to let everyone know
of how entertainment uh based this kind
of video is wow wow that's crazy
I'm glad I'm glad that you you know you
stood true to that
um because at the end of the day it's I
think it's actually very important for
Muslims to to fit in you know what I
mean I don't mean that we assimilate and
we just give up our value whoever there
is Common Ground we should find common
ground with these people
um like someone's gonna say what do you
mean these
you said it best in in the video we
don't care about getting canceled we
don't care what people think if people
want to come at me for a few words and
inshallah no worries so um speaking of
you brother John how are you you know as
the the video progressed did you become
more or less comfortable with the
discussion I know I would say the same
thing as I just want to make sure we're
getting this right so I'm not bitching
islamia right or is it how do you want
to say it so it's it's it's okay I kind
of like got used to the many many
pronunciations of my name so but the
correct Arabic ways
okay yeah I'll do my best
I'll say uh same thing as her and um I
got more comfortable throughout the
shoot I'm not sure if you noticed the
first question if you watch it
um we're talking about hijab
um that you you if you watch me like I'm
shaking a little bit I'm a little bit
shaking even though I I have a good
answer and I was happy with what I said
but like what I'm delivering it I was
shaking a little bit uh and then I
started to settle in I was like okay
this is how it's gonna be I'm like it's
not there's like maybe 15 20 people in
this room because we like to be worried
about
um but as he went on that was good I
would like to I mean everyone I think
everyone kept their composure um on both
sides
um except for when you you saw in the
video there was one time it got heated
but other than that
um everyone kept I would say for the
most part their emotions in check
um the goal was to not make it an
emotional argument like at least for for
me and I think for us
um the goal is to make it like a logical
and like an uh a based argument with
some uh some sort of some sort of
evidence
um so once I figured out how the
structure was going to go and we did the
first question I was like okay like this
is how it's gonna be I was like this is
this is pretty easy so
um yeah definitely got I think I got
more comfortable throughout the
throughout the shoot
very good to hear all right so with that
being said I want to get kind of deeper
into the actual discussion itself so I
have prepared a little video with some
clips from it and I made her I made sure
to select the two I'd say the two
instances where it seems like there was
no real end to the discussion
um and I think honestly you guys did an
amazing job with what you were given and
the reason I say that
is uh it's simply because you there
isn't really much room to be able to
make full-on arguments or to respond to
the intricacies of what they're saying
or to look at someone and say well
that's a little off topic you're just
kind of going on an emotional rant right
now
um and I don't think people would take
too kindly to that on that kind of
platform either
so
um I'll give you guys a chance while I
find the video just to kind of give any
general thoughts um not too specific but
just general about the whole shoot and
everything if you want to go more to the
entertainment side of it I think that
would be great as well because people
don't see it behind the scenes right so
I want to hear about that yeah so uh
first of all I want to say uh okay just
disclaimer I haven't seen the actual
video yet only I've only seen Clips what
I've heard that one of the things and I
told Jed before right this is just oh no
um I've heard I've heard from my friends
and everyone who's seen it you know
there's a lot of stuff that for instance
either I said or other people that said
that that was taken out of the video
um whether it was uh productive or not
for instance we talked about Shia versus
Sunni we talked about uh the Iran issue
we talked about
um
a lot of points that we've said uh I
believe it was taken out obviously for
the time constraint but also
um maybe maybe it wouldn't have fit into
their agenda I'm not sure to be honest
you know uh it is what it is you know
but um you know alhamdulillah I think we
it's all inshallah this that the video
has some sort of benefit you know for
the people that actually want to listen
you know because I looked at some of the
comments you know and there's obviously
people who just have like a brick wall
of a heart you know where they don't
want to listen to anything as we saw in
the video you know they got to a point
where
I'm sure the the the point where judge
was talking about where he got heated
yeah I kind of sat back and I know you
can see my facial expression you know
I was very my blood was boiling in that
part but
you know it it gets to the point where
you know whatever you say it's not it's
going to go through one year after the
other for the other person you know so
there's only so much you can do in that
way and also they keep cutting you off
so that's like
yeah absolutely and I think that's the
downside for Muslims to go on you know
non-muslim platforms
um because they can really do whatever
they want
um and if you if you look at like
Muhammad hijab actually was talking
about Piers Morgan and one of his
conditions for going on Piers Morgan
show for an interview is that he can
also record on his end and that's
because they cut the video up and they
try and catch you off guard and then
well as soon as they do they'll clip it
and they'll plaster everywhere and say
you know
um extreme Muslim blah blah blah you
know whatever the headline is so um but
regardless I think you guys definitely
held up very very well alhamdulillah so
I have the video here I'm gonna pull it
up now it might automatically play
all right so very very popular one let's
just let's just jump into it
why is this an issue only now but not in
all of this time of Islam it's always
been an issue
the climate we're living nowadays the
liberal mind isn't queer since the
beginning of time
and people have acted upon that there's
poetry there's erotic
feeling if you look at every other
religion that's a sin in every religion
it's not up to me for it to interpret
that's why
you look up to the people with knowledge
you look up to the people who have
dedicated their lives to interpreting
this
that's what I'm saying I can't you can't
ignore all the scholars of the 1400
years I'm not ignoring them but it's you
can't just say they're the only ones who
are correct I just told you it's not
just words
two compared to thousands
[Music]
you're all very passionate about this
topic but I think that's not going to be
a middle round which is okay yeah I
think the point is to still have a
conversation and I appreciate that you
guys are still listening to each other
and talking but we have to move on to
the next prompt
all right so uh got pretty heated there
um I want to start with with brother Jad
because it felt like it was me at the
end it was mainly him and other people
going at it before the director jumped
in so brother Jad what were you thinking
in that moment
sell my cash right here you guys see
what's up
um so what I was thinking in that moment
oh my God if you look at what's
happening right before then
um
I answered so every time
um anybody else was speaking I would say
that we were all
um as in like us three we were very
respectful and we made sure that
everyone got their whole entire point
across and I never I don't think
throughout the entire thing I didn't
interrupt anyone I don't think any of us
interrupted anyone and that's out of
respect because I would like that's how
I would want to be treated when I'm
speaking and when I'm answering in this
specific prompt
um Natalie brings up a point and then I
address it and then she responds and I'm
about to address her again but then once
I start responding she just continuously
Cuts me off and I could not get my point
across and then obviously this is an
emotional topic for her so
I I just got I just couldn't get my
point across and then by the time I
wanted to the discussion had shifted to
someone else and I wasn't gonna be like
let me get my point across like it
wasn't and you have to understand that
it's a room of six people and a limited
amount of time so for everyone to be
able to get the point across is going to
be difficult
um but I even told the director I took
her aside and I said look I was like
there's certain things I'm okay with you
cutting me off on but I was like there's
other things where like they're saying
some pretty crazy stuff that needs to be
addressed
um for example sorry this is a little
actually no this kind of because I
brought up a Hadith in this in this a um
Topic in the in the homosexuality one I
said one of the worst sins of mankind is
the sin of the people of loot
um
and then uh Natalie was like there's
only like 70 Hadith that are like um
unambiguously true and like uh and that
are like authentic and I was like
I was like okay so we have like we have
a fundamental like error here that we
need that needs to be addressed because
if I don't address this I can't argue
with you about something more detailed
like this is this is something else
that's more important so we actually me
and Mahmoud I think we talked about
maybe I had the science of Hadith in the
video for about five minutes it's
nowhere to be found
um but
I mean it's it was a little bit
frustrating especially in that moment I
had a lot a lot to say Obviously that's
the longest segment in the video I think
a lot of people had a lot to say
um
but like me and my mother's uh said even
uh lamia said throughout multiple times
in the video it's not about what we have
to say it's about
I have to say and
okay our goal was to just put it out
there what is setting up put in about
this
says about this topic
and obviously it was going to get heated
I mean when someone is
that emotionally invested into that
topic like I get it
um but I think
it's important to respect the other
people trying to have a conversation
with you and just whenever you're in
that situation whenever you're in like a
debate or something like that one of the
biggest things if is like respecting the
other person on the other side of the
table so that's what I think about that
absolutely absolutely
um I I when I I don't know if you guys
know I did a reaction my personal
Channel about this and when I got to
that part I was just like flabbergasted
that she would make such an argument
because like what are you what are you
really saying yeah we have certain
Hadith that are Musa water meaning that
the transmission of those Hadith were
just as certain as in the transmission
of those Hadith as we are in the
transmission of the Quran right then
there are some that they're not like to
the level of the Quran but they're still
authentic they're still like if you
disagree with them it's like what you're
saying is baseless we still have the
sahih
um so it was just such a strong man it
was a bit sad to see that but um you
could tell she's she's been prepped
before I think by liberal Scholars or
whatever you want to call them with
these arguments she's done research on
this
um I think maybe this is the first time
she engages someone who maybe knew what
they were talking about
um because I don't think she would have
made such a sharing about Allah so
brother Mahmoud the clip started with
you saying why is this a problem only in
our day like only today in our climate
do you want to discuss a little more
about that and go a little more in depth
because I think she kind of just started
yeah
yeah okay first of all um me and Jed we
made like kind of a reaction type video
with uh with another shift uh it's on
YouTube right now where higuchi knows
these quote-unquote Scholars she's
talking about and refutes them by the
way what's what's the name of the
channel uh it's on my friend's Channel
called uh when you type in Jubilee uh
the name of the video it has the same
title so it's very easy to find okay
okay it was a couple thousand views but
it's fine whatever yeah but um
yes
um the whole like jazz was saying right
now you know there's there was too many
fundamental issues here you know for
instance the Jamar you know the the
opinions of the scholars the agreeance
of the scholars here Hadith
like I was saying the the the accepting
of only 70 Hadith or whatever I think
that's a Shiite thing that she probably
brought up
um third of all uh except in Quran these
are three fundamental keys of evidence
in Islam and if you're if you're trying
to talk out of your behind in this way
sorry for my uh language like that but
if you're trying to talk with ignorance
about that that's a big big issue and
exactly why me and Jack came to the
producer or the director and said you
know this is very unproductive for the
conversation I believe you know
especially when we talked about Hadith
you know but um but yes going back to
the scholar thing you know you know
subhanallah I'm not I'm not sure if it's
in the video or not but I was talking I
remember talking about this that's why
I'll bring it up you know as Muslim we
take we take our source from problem
you know and this is from Hadith right
right the best generations
and so on right those are the best
Generations in chronological order right
and we got the most Scholars from each
other from from that time right from the
from the sahaba and then there are
students at tavirin the generation after
then right so
the fact that these kind of like you
said straw man arguments are coming out
nowadays you know and then that kind of
that thing said about uh erotic poetry
or whatever I don't understand what that
even means you know but the fact that
that's even brought up is just you know
for people of Reason Not Muslims are not
Muslims if you're watching the video
you'll understand what we're saying you
understand that this is just like
complete nonsense completely uh
illegitimacy you know but um in Islam
you know our Scholars from the past you
know they've done the complete research
they've dedicated their life to this you
know and there's another part of the
video where they go where that person
says something about bias of the
scholars or something you know what are
they biased about they're biased about
it just I can't I can't put in my head
to understand
yeah I actually they they did leave it
in and that was another point that I
mentioned that um if you if you take
what you know how God mentioned the
thousands of Scholars from the past and
then the like like I cannot stress the
vast minority of Scholars today who is
really biased
is it the people that read the Quran and
Sunnah the same Quran the same Hadith
you know the same works of the scholars
it's very similar osul and principles
for the last thousand years or is it the
people that just happen to have the
opinion that their country agrees with
who's more biased
um is it was really you know crazy for
me to hear um her make that kind of
claim you know given reality exactly and
you know this comes out of ignorance you
know you know Allah keep us on the
straight path and keep guide us all you
know it's not you know Allah
you know that's why this also it gets to
a point where
like where we don't we have to try not
to have arrogance and we have to try to
have just calm calmness you know and
give our our facts you know yeah but
that's the problem with this kind of
this channel you know where it looks
like there's some actual
quote unquote um uh valid side to this
argument when it's completely not you
know it's just it's just uh garbage but
yeah absolutely all right sister let me
I want to bring it you know to you now
where where were you you know when these
conversations were happening you heard
you know the sister saying what she was
saying what were you thinking and did
you interject and um and if you could go
back today what would you add on to the
conversation
so I would definitely add so after
um
Jad recited that one eye of the Quran
um
don't have it memorized but uh
um Natalie said that there's a
interpretation of that one Ayah that
kind of like suits the liberal
perspective
um and if you can see in the video I am
sitting there confused I did not
understand what she was saying I was
trying to understand what she was saying
but I just couldn't I couldn't unders
like I I couldn't get what that
reinterpretation is because it is it's a
clear Ayah I don't think
there's two three opinions on this um so
I was gonna ask her okay let's just say
let's just assume that there's this
reinterpretation of yours for that one
Ayah what about the many other ayas that
kind of um band home or acting upon
homosexual just for Concepts when I say
homosexuality here I mean acting upon
homosexuality but instead of just saying
the whole thing I'm just gonna say
homosexuality but like um what what what
about the other the many other ayat that
kind of manhole what about the Hadith
what about the many many scholarship
interpretations of these Quran and the
Hadith and if that is not enough let's
take it to to a bigger scope um we know
that we as Muslims believe that
Christianity and Judaism
um are also monolithic religions mean
Allah right that's the that's what we
believe as Muslims so um
homosexuality is a sin also in
Christianity and Judaism so I was I was
just
I was just trying to like see what her
explanations would be in those cases
because
you know yeah 100 100 and even this is
the thing even with that kind of
interpretation it doesn't make sense
with what she was saying because she was
saying Allah Allah is not saying are you
basically sleeping with men instead of
women Allah is saying are you leaving
the the women you're with for men and
I'm like that doesn't really change
anything because Allah is saying are you
leaving the woman you're permissible to
be with for men it doesn't really change
anything and even you know take it a
step further and I'm going to use the
you know the r I'm not going to say the
r word because I don't want to get
flagged here but I think we know what
we're talking about with that whole
interpretation let's just replace the
word approach with the r word do you
RP men instead of women does that make
any more sense to you
are you rp'ing men instead of women how
would that fit into what Islam actually
promotes so you know obviously Islam is
very far from you know that kind of
Injustice and those disgusting uh those
disgusting things right and um and I
also kind of added this one point I I
don't think I I don't even know if it's
included in the in the video but I asked
um we know that procreating is
he said it in many instances that you
know
as soon as it has for us to kind of
procreate as humans so
um if someone acts upon homosexuality
and and kind of like
obtains kids in a very natural way how
does that kind of like
um
contribute to our kind of like
whole purpose I I like I don't want to
say whole purpose because that kind of
seems like you know but like how does
that kind of help in in kind of making
more of us humans who kind of like you
know become
um
so what I'm trying to say is like
so Allah
um uh the humans and and the gint only
for the purpose of serving me how are we
supposed to keep that going or growing
if we are not procreating so yeah 100
100 very beautifully said and um again
you I mean a good point to bring it back
to is is for everyone you know watching
just understand that whatever these
people are saying is coming from a
secular liberal Western unislamic point
of view you know you have to ask
yourself the the tough questions and the
objective question were people saying
these things before the west intervened
where people saying these things before
our lands were colonized were people
saying these things before are you know
people started pushing this secular
liberal agenda uh look at the evidence
the answer is no people are not saying
these things uh there was a huge
emphasis on growing the ummah and there
was a huge emphasis on teaching Islam
and
um and basically holding on to Allah and
the messenger Allah say specifically
um so I think we've we've outdone that
that topic quite a bit if you guys have
any final words to add on that inshallah
please jump in if not then if you want
to uh hopefully a less uh distraught
discussion I have one more thing I want
to say it's not just directly towards
this topic but just in general yeah when
you
first of all you become a Muslim or for
those of us who are born Muslim
um
what you understand is as a Muslim
the second you become a Muslim or what
you are a Muslim you are
a slave to Allah and
the biggest fight that you're gonna
fight your whole life is against your
nest is against yourself
and if you can't
fight your desires to please Allah
then you're failing to yourself because
the whole idea of being a Muslim is
fighting your desire to please Allah if
you try to switch that around and make
your desire pleasing to Allah it's not
going to work you can't adjust the Deen
to your desires the second you start
doing that it's an endless loop you're
gonna keep trying to justify your
desires and keep trying to find ways to
prove that you're right when there is
concrete evidence for everything like
rahmoud was saying earlier Islam is not
just
praying five times a day and fasting on
my bun Islam is a way of life right
Islam tells you everything from
from walking into the bathroom to how to
handle divorce to literally anything
um anything you have a question about in
your life can be answered by the Quran
Sunnah so the second you start trying to
adjust the Deen to fit your desires
there's a there's a there's a weakness
there and there's something that needs
to be addressed and none of us none of
us are perfect no human in this world is
perfect
um
and it's okay to have moments of
weaknesses the the problem is when you
try to justify that moment of weakness
instead of saying that what I'm doing is
wrong like no um what I'm doing isn't
wrong what you guys are saying is wrong
like
Islam says it needs to be changed like
that's when you start to cross a get
into like a gray area not even a gray
area even a little bit more than that
um yeah so just fighting the battle of
the nests and the second you're able to
admit that you're wrong not only in
Islam but just in life if you're eight
months a second you're able to admit
that you're wrong in something you're
going to grow as a person and I think
it's extremely important to learn from
your mistakes and learn that I'd admit
that what you're doing is a sin I guess
I am sitting it's something that I'm
having trouble with
um but I'm not going to try justifying
it
so I think it's just
that's my point is don't try to make the
dean fit your desires try to
have your uh just keep fighting your own
Battle of the Neffs and uh try to fit
your desires like try to
get I don't know I'm gonna mess it up I
don't want to say anything wrong but you
gotta understand what I'm trying to say
yeah yeah we have to control our enough
to not love her Allah says have you seen
the one who takes their own desires
their enough as their own God exactly um
so we want to avoid that Insha'Allah
um brother or sister you guys have
anything else to add before we jump into
the uh the next part of the vid
I have something but I'll bring it up
because it goes into every topic and it
goes into exactly what I just said from
the Quran so I'll bring it up later
okay time inshallah noise let me let's
continue with this
any reinterpretation of the Quran I
believe is uh incorrect because
then what would differ the Quran from
the Bible and so
so such slavery still be a thing I want
to pause it there actually I'm going to
rewind that a little bit
so we can hear the question again
so such slavery still be a thing
wow so I that's that's enough to get us
uh talking for a little bit inshallah
what were your immediate thoughts when
you guys heard that well it was because
I was the one I brought up the first
point right
so if you look at I want you to play One
More Time look at
so what we did with that from the Bible
right so look at her reaction the second
I say that and then
incorrect because
then what would differ the Quran from
the Bible and so
so such slavery still be a thing she
doesn't know what to say to that yeah so
that she makes up slavery I was like I
was like what did I miss something
well because I know like now that I
watched it back I was like I have no
idea what I was about to say I started
saying something I have no idea what I'm
about to say I remember talking I was
like yeah but you got this one
you know let me say something uh this
topic I literally okay so I just opened
a tick tock account and I literally just
made two videos about this you know
um so
slavery in the cinema you know I'm not
sure how much of it is in the video what
I was saying but as we know you know
slavery that word slavery alone has the
negative context of the American slavery
right sleeping in the time of the
problem and in the time in the time
ignorance of the Arabs before Islam was
not the slavery of now of of the modern
context of African-Americans being being
based off of race whipping treating them
like animals it's not the same right we
know this you know but people who don't
look into history want to talk out out
of ignorance right so
like Dad just brought up you know as we
saw that I don't want to say names or
anything but she had no argument so she
wants to bring up to this you know and
her argument doesn't even make sense
right as we don't understand and
everywhere in the Quran whenever he
mentions slavery it only mentions
freeing of slaves right I could bring up
three ads right now I don't think it's
productive for the conversation but I'll
maybe you can leave it in the
description or something all right I
lost my data always for for different
punishments based off of for instance
one person not leaving a a saying of a
correct oath
uh for killing someone unjustly or uh by
accident the the
the the the thing to do is to free a
slave or other things right is is the
always most gracious most merciful right
the the fact that that was brought into
this thing it just it just shows the
level of con uh competency I'm sorry to
say that but you know if someone this is
a public platform so I I don't have any
problem with talking about that you know
because it's just completely uh
incorrect you know in this and that you
know for instance the problem is
given as a quote-unquote slave from
right but he treat him as a son he
treated him as a his uh his own son and
ended up you know this long story short
he would say he stayed with him and
everything in Islam from the time of the
zero uh is about freeing slaves and
keeping them as part of the um
and also the slaves had the the
opportunity to free themselves you know
and it's not like I said whether in
shackles being whipped all day it's not
that it was not that you know but
I know kind of going to attend you here
but yeah
no absolutely absolutely she actually I
think that this is something that she
had prepared beforehand or somebody
helped to prepare beforehand because
um and it's a completely emotional
argument because whenever someone makes
a a moral argument it's basically
useless and there's no point continuing
to that conversation because morality
and I think I think we mentioned this
you asked what dictates like objective
morality what dictates what is
objectively right and wrong that's a
great question because it is not the
majority of people it is not the elites
it's not the people on top it's not the
you know Western white man that dictates
what is moral and immoral it uh can only
be Allah that tells us objectively what
is right and she mentioned when it was
only her and uh that brother Zane
um the thing about slavery and it's it's
such a tremendous disservice to I think
even call it that because as you
mentioned it has a bad connotation of
the cross-atlantic slave trade
um where me you could say that kind of
um disgusting slavery existed before
Islam came but did not exist after Islam
came and I think that is such a
beautiful point to make and um Allah
specifically says in the Quran I think
this is one of the Ayah ayat that you
mentioned
um shall I inform you of the good way
the good way is freeing slaves so all
over you know we are encouraged to free
slaves and if you investigate and if she
actually did the due diligence of
investigating she would see the beauty
behind on this kind of presentation in
Islam because the only time someone can
end up and I'm going to use the word
servant now because slaves just does not
fit yeah anytime someone ends up as a
servant it's only because they end up
being a prisoner of war which means they
as an individual or their people people
went to war against the Muslims and they
lost now they have three options when
you're in that situation you have three
options and I would love for someone to
bring a fourth option either you kill
everyone
or you let everyone go free and then
risk them retaliating again or you take
them as prisoners what is the third
option the reason this is such a great
option is because you take them as
prisoners and then with freeing them
over time allowing them to Ransom
themselves you allow them to integrate
into Islamic society and see how
generous and good the Muslims are
how beautiful Islam is and so on and so
forth and this was something that worked
the prophet sallam did it the Muslims
did it at the time and there is no
contention with it and with that we were
you know forced by Allah to feed them
with the same food that we eat clothe
them with the same clothes that we wear
and if anyone if a Muslim were to even
hit or harm their servants in any way
then I I believe they would be freed or
at the very least that person does not
get uh does not uh you know this is not
going to be um in charge of them uh as
you know their their
um captor or whatever you want to call
it so now let's have her ask that same
question again you know
now it makes no sense because even what
she's referring to didn't exist in the
time of the Prophet so sorry I know I
went on a bit of a rant there
um just something you know I guess I
think we're all very upset when she made
such a straw man argument but sister
lemia
what were your thoughts when she brought
that up
atheist versus Muslim
um
uh was that agnostic versus Muslim
debates and usually that's the this
topic specifically is always the one
that's brought up so is Islam justifying
slavery and all that so
um I was just maybe I was maybe
surprised that a Muslim would actually
brought that up against you know uh like
in this situation it was out of context
as well I feel but
um
I I feel like Mahmoud here he kind of um
he gave her a really good answer is that
slavery was not the the like the slavery
we know today or existed today I
personally am not very knowledgeable in
the topic that's why I did not engage in
it but I learned a lot from you right
now um from Mahmoud so but in the topic
of the reinterpretation of the Quran for
the 21st century um I disagreed in that
specifically because and I think uh Jad
here said something about
um when Allah he revealed the Quran and
Allah is all knowing so he knows the
past the present and the future so when
uh the Quran was revealed it was made
for all times and um who is better than
interpreting the Quran then those
Scholars who kind of dedicated their
entire lives to kind of
um reinterpreting or interpreting the
Quran so it doesn't make sense for each
one of us to kind of interpret it
nowadays based on our own biases yeah
absolutely 100 and with the even with
the word reinterpret whenever you you
know like look at the word to redo
you're doing something over there's
always a reason for redoing something
you know to do it better or to do it
more correctly or to make it more
efficient so it implies you're going
back to correct something or change
something so what are you reinterpreting
it based on what is causing this
reinterpretation and what lets you know
that this reinterpretation is actually
valid now the only
clear answer is that while these
non-muslims live this certain way
but is that enough of a justification
islamically what does Allah says
he says that you have your Deen and and
we have ours that's it listen you can
think what you want you can believe what
you want Islam is not here to command
you to believe XYZ it's here to tell you
what the truth is and Allah says whoever
basically you know intends goodness for
them for themselves they can come and
they can accept it but they won't except
if Allah Wills them to so at the end of
the day you know no one can God they
want to accept Allah
um and I think I'm gonna put up the clip
just to finish with the video and then
we'll go to um brother Jaden Mahmoud
inshallah for their thoughts
no but anyway okay the slaver is a whole
other topic slavery in the timing the
prophet was not the same as the trans uh
whatever the the act of owning another
human being that's a whole other thing
they were basically just a servant they
could buy their own Freedom they could
they had rights they weren't treated
like an animal like how as we see in our
history in America how it was you know
this is not what it was going back to
the actual prompt the the Quran is is in
the people it's a mercy for the humans
Allah gave us to right the Quran is the
words of Allah right of God in the
simplest form I just believe that the
Quran is like a sacred text and sacred
text says a whole just should not be
touched when I think about
reinterpretations I almost think about
like amendments in a way if we believe
that the prophet peace man to him is the
last and final messenger then whatever
he was was revealed to him it is that
you can't reinterpret everything because
the second you open up one thing for
reinterpretation you're opening up the
whole religion for reinterpretation it's
not opening up the whole religion the
religion itself is Devotion to Allah
alone that is what Allah says in Surat
al-baqarah that Islam equals Devotion to
a religion to Islam equals Devotion to
Allah alone
of course okay well
if if you are devoting yourself to Allah
then
um when did Allah change his mind did he
give anyone a new revelation or bring
the prophetam back to instruct us that
no this was abrogated and now you can do
XYZ
um it's kind of silly but the
conversation ended abruptly there she
just said oh Islam equals Devotion to
Allah and it's like Oh Happy Endings
like whoa you didn't finish the
conversation so I want you guys insha
Allah to be able to add what you would
have added or maybe say what was not
included that you mentioned originally
um yeah that was one of my bigger points
I was like
if you believe that the Quran was being
reinterpreted
what are you really questioning because
the Quran is Allah's word and we believe
Allah I asked them before you go and
it's in the video I said is everyone
here believe Allah knows the scene in
the Unseen everyone said yes I was like
okay so then we all believe that Allah
before the Quran was revealed knew what
Society was going to be like today knows
it was going to be like in a thousand
years and knows it was like a thousand
years ago so when that animals revealed
it was not just revealed for that time
period it was revealed for all of us and
um
so today the Quran has been uh Nadine
has been perfected so like that's it the
Dina's been perfected there's no more
there's no more going back and
readjusting anything at that point
you're questioning Allah and his
messenger and then you're getting into a
scary area so that's why I mean just
even the fact that I'm sure I think I
remember I watched your video a little
bit I don't know if I got to this part
but just like the reaction that we had
or do you even I think it's in the video
you see him like me and mahmoud's
reaction when when like we actually see
people like walk up I was like there's
no way I was like I was like the other
ones I was like I knew they were gonna
walk up I was like this one I'm like I'm
really praying like we haven't gotten
there
and then they walked up I was like all
right it's gonna be interesting
um
but yeah I mean
we all are on the same page and it's
just frustrating at the end of the day
it's frustrating because you want of
course we want everyone to be guided and
we may throw out that the the people in
this video and everyone watching is
guided inshallah
um
but it was just frustrating that we
couldn't
communicate with our what we were saying
wasn't being communicated properly I
guess or it wasn't really I feel like
the other side maybe wasn't there to to
listen they were just there to say their
points and make sure that it was heard
rather than listening to what had to be
said
yeah absolutely do you want to add on to
that yeah I was just going to bring up
the I haven't sorted earlier on lost my
data talking about the different kind of
verses in the Quran and I brought those
up in the video but I don't think it was
in there
you know Allah telling us how there's
different ayats in the Quran
um
right ones with definite meaning
this is literally what we have to do and
ones with more ambiguous meaning you
know and that's not and then Allah tells
us that the people with like a
perversity or like disease in their
heart these are the people that want to
take the the shabby had
me the more ambiguous ones and change it
based on their desires and cost Fitness
for the people right yeah so as we see
this is exactly what happened in the
video and but the funny part is that she
did not the person did not take the uh
uh
you know literally about
uh other ones about a lot of other
things you know you know so it just goes
to show you know the the like you said
strawman argument and
you know it's just it's just it's very
it's very sickening to see someone who
no no no way just anyone in general who
just doesn't have a holistic view of
Islam to come on and just uh give their
views and talk about it in that way not
saying I'm perfect or any of us are
perfect you know but at least we have
some basic knowledge of a basic uh
understanding of a synonym which is
exactly what we try to do it's not in
the video but you know we just want to
always bring it back to tahit you know
we live in Allah
uh talked about uh organic Iman even in
the video you know it wasn't in there
but it's just always about bringing it
back to this you know because at the end
of the day
all these topics in the video are not
they go Islam goes into them you know
but this is not the full thing of a
synonym like oh we go to the mission and
all we learned about is homosexuality or
marrying four wives and you know this is
like this is just like small things you
know like not obviously they're Grand
things but small things in in the old in
the actual message of tohed and what all
the prophets came to and then the
prophecy from Muhammad given the last
message of it you know
so it's just frustrating to see how it
Islamic has dumbed down to this yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely and when what
I'm glad you mentioned that this is not
something that we you know these are not
the only things we talk about in Islam
um I just want to add that these things
are not
um like we don't classify People based
on their sexuality in Islam that's
something only the West does the West
are you know they're the ones that will
come and say okay you're you're gay
you're straight you're trans you're this
Islam doesn't really have
classifications for these people because
it's not a big deal Islam doesn't give
such focus on these things it's only the
west and it's because they have such
strong opinions basically against what
we believe I think a really good example
of Muhammad of what you're trying to say
that the sister did was when she
mentioned that Allah says in the Quran
that he puts basically he put something
between mates so that we can find
Tranquility in them and she used the
word mate
um and she didn't mention for example
Allah says he put between a man and a
woman passionate love and mercy you know
and and that just goes to show how
willing people are to twist the words of
Allah and it the four of us don't have a
lot of knowledge this as you mentioned
is very basic stuff so you don't need an
Islam or a scholar actually I don't
think the items or the scholars should
waste their time talking with with these
about you know these people about these
things they only require you know people
like myself who don't have a lot of
knowledge because they're very easily
refuted so may Allah bless all of you
guys immensely for putting in that work
for the sake of Allah no matter how
stressful it might have been I think you
guys did all honestly all did a
tremendous job and uh as we close off
this stream here very soon I want to get
the final thoughts from you guys and
maybe a few questions from the people
watching we'll start with sister uh
limia if you have any final thoughts
[Music]
um
I mean I don't have any like General
final thoughts I guess um like I said
there are some things
um for example like I would I would love
to like kind of like add on I wish I I
said in the video like for example the
first very first question was about the
hijab
um I think that is a topic that for me
kind of put um hits close to home
because
um I I'm not a hijabi myself
um but I think I saw this even like
alehdini I hope one day that I I do gain
the the
the strength and the ability to kind of
overcome that and and and and where the
hijab inshallah but um the the prompt
that said that um a good Muslim woman
wears the hijab I I think I kind of I
was conflicted about whether I kind of
agreed or disagreed with that problem
because
um I I took it from both a technical and
like a general side
um I technically
um the hijab does not really determine
whether a Muslim is is good or not um
it's just because
you'll find like a lot of Muslim women
who just wear the hijab to please their
families and the communities and and and
and and like they're they're just
they're small circle and they and they
in many cases they eventually end up
just hating the hijab and that
eventually leads to places like you know
kind of Miskin like misunderstanding the
Islam as something as a religion that is
like based on do's and don'ts you know
you should wear the hijab you should
pray five times a day and all that and
um
it's just for me I just think that um
there are some there are a lot of Muslim
women who do not wear the hijab horse or
her it's true to their faiths you know
they kind of stick to their face and and
and are Yani this is going to sound bad
but they are actually better than some
of Muslim women who do wear the hijab so
um I just want to Ramble On on this
topic a lot but because this just hits
close to home to me and I I did go over
some of the comments in the YouTube
um the the Jubilee video saying that oh
I'm a hypocrite because of I'm not
wearing the hijab and all that I'm
saying I'm conservative so I just wanted
to address that real quick that um
wearing the hijab does not make you a
good Muslim woman
it's just that some people kind of do
wear it for other reasons than the true
purpose of it which is protection for
the for the woman so um but like I said
inshallah inshallah one day it's a work
in progress but I just wanted to clear
that up yeah that was actually really
well said um it's funny because when I
did my reaction my initial reaction was
the exact opposite of what the people in
the comments are saying I actually had
praised you for saying that because a
lot of people are you know they would
just give in to well I don't do it I
don't want to feel like hypocrite Sonic
hypocrite so I'm just gonna say actually
I don't need to wear hijab but you on
the other hand you understood that Islam
and Allah has made it an obligation and
that that's something that you're
working on and to those people who
commented that I would say you know um
narrated uh I don't know if there's a
Hadith number if he himself said it but
he said the actions are judged by their
intentions meaning that yes whether it's
wearing hijab or praying Salah or giving
in charity if you do it for the sake of
your Community or the sake of people
seeing you you know do these things
without doing it for the sake of Allah
you you know you won't get the good deed
in some cases you might actually be
sinful you know we know the Hadith where
he says the first people that will help
fire one is a scholar another is a
charitable person another person is a
martyr because these are good actions
that they did for the wrong reason so
just like any other action hijab can be
put on for a good reason and for maybe
even a bad reason and on top of that
there is no such thing as one action
that basically deems you a good person
because what if you were hijab you're
given charity previous law but then you
you're abusive to your parents you know
is that person still a good person I
think many people would jump and say I
don't care if they're wearing hijab and
praying they're clearly not a good
person but uh Muhammad and brother John
what do you guys have to say
I'm glad I'm glad sister lamia was able
to get that out
um I think was important and yeah people
were being disrespectful in the comments
um I'm glad that you were able to say
and I'm also a complete agreement with
what you said and what brother Rami just
said
um
um I think people are getting a
um
a misconception that uh that some of us
here just because I I brought up a few I
asked in the video or whatever they
think I'm a scholar or something like
that I want to make it clear I am not a
lot of Chef or anything like that I'm
just a regular Muslim alhamdulillah
doing his best
um
like I said before thank you to everyone
who was like being extremely kind and
telling me that we did really well in
the video and stuff but there's people
sending me uh uh these questions
um I have no place to answer that guys
um I just want to make that clear and I
think that was a compliment yeah I
appreciate you guys thinking that I'm
able to answer that but I'm not I'm not
in the position to be giving you as a
festival
um
and have the lights easy for
for like us like for it to get to your
head like oh yeah I was on this video
like 900 000 views I'm like yeah or
whatever like you guys ask me whatever
you want it's like I think it's really
easy uh for it to get to your head and
like
for you to tell yourself that yeah like
okay like you are better than these
people
um but I think it's always about being
humble I ask um now especially I'm out
of making
a difference because it's scary like if
any of this I'm not doing for the sake
of Allah
then rather than this all being a reward
for me it could it could just go the
opposite way and um alhamdulillah I
think the group of people that we have
here
um I don't doubt that any of us are
doing this for the sake of Allah and I
don't think any of us are doing this for
our own personal benefit
um I am really happy I will say I'm
happy that this is giving me a platform
to to spread the dean and um
and at least connect with the Muslim
youth I think we're in a we're in a
difficult place right now with where we
are in society uh there's a lot a lot of
problems that we're facing out like
there's so much you can't even blame
them obviously I'm a youth as well but I
I feel so bad for the kids though this
the environment that they're growing up
in
um so many questions that they're gonna
they have to ask what they're being
taught at school and and the friends
that they have how they're gonna how are
they supposed to be making friends with
these people the people who go to public
school like how
like there's just so many so many
questions like am I allowed to say this
am I allowed to do this like should I be
hesitant to do this it's like I can't
imagine what it's like right now when I
graduated class of 2020 in high school I
was like
me when I graduated in terms of like
the people in my class
from what I knew that were like maybe
like homosexual maybe like
are you gonna count on your hand
not from what I'm hearing I have little
cousins I I kid you not little cousins
that are like 11 and 12 telling me
stories about they have people walking
around there's walking around school
with their with their boyfriend on a on
a what's it called a leech and a leash
and um
like kids 11 years old talking about
committing suicide and
like it's just unbelievable I I really
don't know like that's why I'm trying to
I want to do my best to like be a good
influence and reach out to these people
because they need help I mean it's
it's if you don't have someone to look
up to or or the right group of people
around you
uh it's gonna be extremely difficult for
you to stay steadfast so inshallah we
can help those people out and I think
that's that's the goal inshallah I
appreciate you having us on I'm sure
we're all extremely appreciative and uh
just want to say
I appreciate you all coming on
um before we end the stream brother
Mahmoud do you have any final thoughts
yeah of course you know you know we can
sit here and talk about the video break
it down all we want you know but in the
end of the day we have to take it back
to what is
right the believing Oneness of Allah
submitting to him you know this is the
same message otherwise to them
Ibrahim all the prophets and all of them
professed when we start going into Haram
and all this kind of stuff like how
people like to dumb down is them you
know it just makes it it's not The
Message of Islam no problem in the first
13 years of Mecca it was not about Haram
for the most part you know it's about
building the building that I'll create
the building the hate as well you know
of the the muslimin then when you want
they went to Medina then he got into the
hijab Ghana to uh all these different
kind of things that now we know as
default Islam you know subhanallah and
then brought up the uh
about the this Dean being completed you
know I just want to you know it's a sad
climate like we're in like exactly a job
we're just saying you know where where
uh yes of course we have we have the the
non-muslimine uh abiding by these very
disgusting ways of life even in our
schools being taught it but then we have
the numbers I mean we have the Muslim
abiding by unfortunately as well as we
saw in the video as we see little kids
because they're confused about it you
know yeah and this goes back to
uh parenting this goes back to Parenting
and also another thing is when when
unfortunately uh because I'm a youth
leader in a mission as well you know
where we see a lot of kids that just
come from they go to public school and
their parents just bring them to the
message thinking oh okay I don't have to
do anything I don't have to teach them
anything just bring them to the mission
and then they'll turn around good you
know it's not the way you know it all
starts from the home you know and I'm
not saying I was raised the best or
anything you know him that I was raised
very blessed most better than most
people on this Earth
because the whole thing here is that we
have to
take take initiative with our own kids
tell them the dean in the correct way
because the the moment we don't they're
just gonna fall into the what's outside
you know and this is seeping into the
Muslim world as well it's not just in
America it's not just in Canada not just
in the west it's in the whole Muslim
world right now as we know this is uh
obviously we're getting close to human
in this way you know so we have to just
steadfast to this and be it's my message
for everyone here and not not for here
but like the viewers you know be proud
of your team understand your Dean always
try to
understand that this Dean is for the
greater purpose Allah gave this he
created
the plan is he created all of us in such
intricate ways what makes us think that
we know how to uh live our lives
randomly by ourselves you know he
created us he knows how to how we act
you know by bardine you know if there's
anything telling it's people what Dean
is in school anything like this you know
yeah I'm [ __ ] rambling now but you
get my point here you know be proud of
the system you know this Islam is
something that you know it was not
blessed with everyone you know you know
and then we were blessed as Muslim
growing up and born in it you know but
that doesn't mean we're gonna die as Mr
I mean you know and some some or some
people we may look at
listening to me you know we don't know
you know the other day we ask Allah to
have the best and to to have a steadfast
steadfast on this on this uh
go on from there you know Allah I mean
Allah very beautifully for everyone
coming on
um it is very important that um we just
focus on what is the truth what does
Allah want from us and um just forget
honestly forget about anything else like
if or better yeah just compare you know
compare the the cost of both ends
compare the cost of being a practicing
Muslim and and compare that with the the
call cost of abandoning your religion
and which one are you going to regret
most long term so let's be strong with
the sake of Allah continue to preach
Islam we don't have to please anybody on
Facebook Earth we do not we don't need
people to be happy with us and the
Muslims are what two billion strong
alhamdulillah who cares if a few people
don't like us
um it's the last question it's a bit of
a funny one in my opinion have you guys
watched the reaction that the twitch
streamer I think he's on Twitch Hassan
Abby did the video
I did watch it I watched
I I think I watched it like two times
speed there was no way I was watching
the whole thing on regular time
he mentioned you specifically he's like
oh bro stop showing off I was like bro I
was like my fault like I was like it was
so funny to me
um
but it was cool I mean it was like cool
that it was like he reacted to it but to
be honest I don't know if yeah I don't
know if he's a Muslim I don't know if
he's I literally I I don't watch the guy
ever I've never watched him
um I know of him I've never watched any
of his uh content or anything uh
but bro hey I mean he wasn't really
saying anything productive at all it was
just to me it was cool that it was being
put on a big platform but
other than that I have like I was like
it is what it is bro like he's he was
like clowning me for for knowing my deal
I guess I was like I was like I I don't
know like you're a copy for that I'm
okay with it but um yeah
yeah based on based on some of the
things I've heard him say I don't think
even if he claims he's Muslim I don't
actually think he's practicing uh and I
don't generally as far as I know I don't
think he's actually a Muslim um because
he seems to uh I don't know his
ideological position
um when it comes to like you know
socialism and all that stuff yeah I I
I'm pretty sure that takes him out of
the full this time because we know that
Islam is a Deen it's a whole ideology in
and of itself not political and
otherwise so um I I think he has to
learn to do if he has a Muslim um but I
just ask Allah to guide him you know if
he is sincere
um to the to the deed of the truth can I
say one last thing okay I'm trying to
say uh let me uh and Judd were saying
and had you around me brought up as well
you know a lot of Muslims as well
watching this video you know those kind
of keyboard Warriors you know you know
you know obviously we're not perfect and
it's just a message for them you know
people that want to make the fear on
everyone and kind of do this whole
negative kind of thing you know this is
nothing this is not it's them one by any
Scholars you know this whole like they
can take fear out of ignorance doing all
this kind of stuff oh look at this and
I'm not talking about even in people in
the video yes they said some crazy
things but in the end of the day we have
no right to suck this
making making uh calling someone a
catheter or uh going into that way you
know this is this is this goes into a
whole uh process you know it's not just
some random guy sees one one thing that
one step person says and just makes a oh
that they're a Catherine and all this
kind of stuff you know this is very
detrimental it's very uh dividing ummah
and this is uh it's very sickening to
see you know because I've seen it on
Twitter I've seen it on Instagram I've
seen it on YouTube you know it's all
kind of people doing against even even
some of the scholars in America you know
like actual Scholars you know it's it's
crazy it's kind of I just want to bring
that up and
you know
all right very beautifully said and I
think that's definitely a great note to
end it on
um I guess there's one more note ended
on Pekka has been attacking Muslims in
Islam since World Cup began he's
whitewashed and paints his nails
sometime okay um bro
um may Allah guide all of us yeah what's
up I have to ask who is this twitch
person I didn't watch the video I'm not
gonna lie so no it's just uh I'm
intrigued this baby at least has a
h-a-s-a-n-a-b-i I think
you'll see you just look it up on
YouTube his reaction or something he
react to the video
yeah but regardless again may Allah you
know continue to guide the Muslims may
Allah guide um everyone Allah I mean and
with that being said everyone for
joining and everyone for attending and
of course thank you so much thank you so
much for having us and we appreciate um
the platform and um continue
representing Islam in the best way
I mean and uh with that being said Allah